Transcriptor: Maite Gistau González
Revisor: Penny Martínez
Tu idea no vale nada.
Lo dijo alguien en Twitter y tiene razón.
Y les voy a decir porqué.
Nos enseñaron que para tener éxito
en una empresa emergente
lo más importante es la idea.
Pensar en una idea fantástica,
que no se le haya ocurrido
nunca antes a nadie.
La idea.
Y que eso nos iba a llevar a esto,
a construir el próximo Nubank,
el próximo Kavak.
Que por inercia
la idea es lo más importante
y que lo demás se va a ir dando.
Pero no es cierto.
Por si acaso, nueve de cada diez empresas
emergentes mueren desde su creación.
Lo cual no quiere decir, que no haya ideas
que sí tengan un valor intrínseco,
pero esas ideas suelen pasar
por un largo proceso de planeamiento,
de trabajo, de investigación
y generalmente están
en industrias como la biotecnología,
la industria farmacéutica
o el “machine learning”.
Pero les voy a decir algo que sí es cierto
y es que toda empresa emergente
o “start-up” pasa por un viaje.
Imagínense que están en Porto
y quieren llegar a Seúl,
es un largo camino con distintas rutas
y ahora mismo no tienen nada.
Bueno, tienen una idea,
pero, como ya dijimos,
su idea no vale nada.
Esa idea va a ir cambiando mañana y pasado
y de aquí a unos años
probablemente sea totalmente distinta.
Lo importante es poder trazar una meta.
¿Qué queremos lograr?
¿Cuál es su Seúl?
Seúl, en esta analogía, es su visión
que, después, dejará de ser solo su visión
y se convertirá en la visión
de toda la empresa.
También aquí vamos a hablar del viaje.
El viaje es la ejecución de su empresa.
Y para eso pensamos que,
si la ejecución es el viaje,
entonces su empresa es el vehículo
y para poder acercarse a su meta
necesitan un buen vehículo.
Aquí tenemos que convencer a cuatro
actores de que se sumen a este viaje.
Y es importante que puedan convencer
a otros a que se sumen a su sueño.
E igual de importante
es que tengan la capacidad
de poder sumarse
al sueño de otras personas.
Porque si nos encontramos
con personas que tienen egos tan grandes
que no pueden
sumarse a la visión de otros,
es muy probable que esas personas
no puedan ser parte de un gran éxito.
En esta primera etapa
sumamos a nuestros copilotos,
nuestras fundadoras y fundadores.
Y aquí hay un poco
de locura e irracionalidad,
porque lo primero que piensa uno
es que no tiene sentido
dejar de hacer lo que está haciendo,
que suele ser algo estable,
para fundar esto nuevo,
que al final no se sabe cómo va a acabar.
Antes de entrar en “tuGerente”,
yo tenía una empresa,
y, antes de tenerla, tenía un trabajo
en una empresa tradicional,
en la que recibía mi sueldo mensualmente
y en la que me gustaba trabajar
y tenía un buen cargo.
Pero llegó un momento
en el que decidí ir a por más
y renunciar a todo eso para entrar
en el mundo de las empresas emergentes
y solucionar problemas de otra forma.
Antes de hacerlo, por supuesto, pensé:
¿qué es lo peor que puede suceder?
Que fracase.
Y ¿qué hago si fracaso? No importa.
Vuelvo a buscar trabajo en otra empresa.
Me pongo a vender algo,
no voy a morirme de hambre.
Y mi empresa fracasó, lamentablemente.
Y antes de que osara volver
de nuevo al mundo corporativo
me invitaron a formar parte de “tuGerente”
Y acepté sin pensarlo,
porque me sentía y me siento identificada
con el problema que resolvemos.
Yo también estuve ahí,
con mis emprendimientos, perdiendo dinero
por tener las finanzas
de mi empresa desordenadas.
Y ahora, ayudo a que podamos llegar,
junto con el resto del equipo,
a conseguir nuestro objetivo final,
nuestra visión y el sueño que compartimos,
que es generar mayor prosperidad
financiera para las pymes.
Es bastante complicado y difícil
lanzarse a la piscina y aprender a nadar.
Pero es igual de difícil y requiere
una mayor apertura de mente
acompañar a esa persona que se lanzó
a la piscina para fundar esa empresa
y comprometerse a hacerla grande.
Los fundadores tienen que compartir
un sueño, una visión.
Seguimos en este camino de locura y ahora
toca encontrar a los primeros clientes.
Tenemos que ser capaces de vender nuestro
producto o servicio a distintas personas,
por más que en ese momento
no sea tan bueno.
Buena suerte con ello.
¿Por qué un cliente
va a querer comprarnos a nosotros
cuando en el mercado
hay todos esos competidores
que ya están consolidados,
y que probablemente tienen un producto
mejor que el tuyo en algunos puntos?
¿Por qué?
Porque algo están haciendo bien.
¿Qué es lo que sucede?
Nuestro vehículo puede ser un poco lento,
puede apagarse de vez en cuando
o tener algunos desperfectos,
como toda empresa al inicio.
Pero lo que construyeron tiene que ser
lo suficientemente valioso
como para que puedan
vendérselo a otras personas.
Y eso suele ser
una cuestión de percepción.
Piensen en las personas que conocen
desde hace muchos años
y que frecuentan día a día.
No nos damos cuenta de cómo cambian.
Ahora piensen en las personas
que conocemos desde hace muchos años
y que nos reencontramos
después de cinco años, un día en el cine.
Sí nos damos cuenta
de cómo ha cambiado esa persona.
En la primera situación,
están nuestros clientes,
los que están con nosotros
desde hace bastante tiempo,
y que no suelen darse cuenta
de cómo va evolucionando el producto.
En la segunda situación,
están los potenciales clientes
o exclientes que ahora están volviendo.
Y que, si están haciendo las cosas bien,
van a ver esa evolución
que ha tenido su producto o servicio.
Tenemos que ser capaces
de sumar esos clientes,
porque sus primeros clientes les compran
porque les cubren una necesidad.
Y vuelven a comprar porque van mejorando,
y así, con el tiempo,
van sumando más y más clientes,
algunos más grandes, otros más exigentes,
porque su vehículo es cada vez mejor.
También están los inversores.
Tenemos que ser capaces
de convencer a personas y empresas
para que inviertan
en lo que hemos construido.
Las probabilidades de que eso suceda
son 300 a 1 en contra
de que un inversor
invierta dinero en su empresa.
¿Y qué pasa entonces?
Vamos por el camino,
y vemos que nuestro depósito
de gasolina está por la mitad,
aún tenemos algo de tiempo, pero no mucho.
Entonces parte de nuestro equipo
va en busca de esos inversores.
Ese camino es un camino largo
y lleno de desmotivaciones,
porque van a escuchar un “no” tras otro,
hasta que lo logren,
hasta que consigan esa inversión.
Y aquí tenemos que ser capaces
de automotivarnos, de reinventarnos
y de comunicar cada vez mejor
el valor que generamos.
¿Y por qué necesitamos
el dinero de los inversores?
Para tener mejores vehículos
que nos acerquen a nuestra visión.
Lo necesitamos para construir un avión,
subir al equipo al avión
y llegar a nuestra meta
más rápido que yendo por tierra.
Pero debemos poder conseguir esa inversión
con el producto que tenemos ahora mismo,
con el equipo que tenemos
y con los resultados
que hemos logrado hasta ese momento.
Al final, al comienzo y en todo momento
están los colaboradores,
esas personas que trabajan con nosotros.
Al inicio, comenzamos
con dos o tres personas.
Probablemente
ya se tienen los primeros clientes,
pero si quieren avanzar
necesitan un gran equipo.
Así que debemos convencer a más personas
de que se sumen a nuestro sueño
y lo conviertan en el suyo.
No importa quién lo soñara primero.
Lo que importa es que todos
queramos lo mismo.
El otro día, una persona que trabaja
con nosotros, un colaborador,
nos contaba por qué le gustaba tanto
trabajar en “tuGerente”.
Nos comentó que, en un momento de su vida,
decidió retirarse de un trabajo
que le encantaba, por todo lo que había
tras el producto que vendía.
Y al retirarse pensó que jamás sentiría
tanta satisfacción con lo que hacía,
hasta que entró en “tuGerente”
y vio cómo luchamos día a día.
Vio que tenemos un propósito mayor
y cómo le cambiamos la vida
a miles de empresas,
generándoles mayores oportunidades.
Esa persona comparte
la visión de “tuGerente”,
tenemos la misma visión.
Para poder alcanzar el éxito
en una empresa emergente,
es fundamental poder convencer
a esos cuatro actores.
No importa el orden en el que suceda,
pero tiene que suceder al inicio.
Al inicio del viaje desde Porto,
a dos manzanas,
ahí tienen que empezar
a aparecer esos actores.
Y los colaboradores,
los clientes y los inversores,
tienen que aparecer a lo largo del camino
una y otra vez para que todo siga rodando.
Esas personas nos ayudarán a alcanzar
el éxito y serán una parte de él.
El éxito.
La de cosas que escuchamos sobre el éxito
y qué pensamos de él.
Pensamos, por ejemplo,
que es llegar a lo más alto.
Cuando ponen en un buscador
de imágenes, en internet,
la palabra “éxito”, la mayoría
de los resultados que aparecen
son de una persona de pie
y con las manos en las caderas,
en la cima de una montaña,
mirando al horizonte.
A algunos hasta les ponen capa.
Pero el éxito es relativo.
Pueden tener éxito con un producto,
y con otro no.
El éxito no es un estado permanente.
Podemos llegar a lo más alto y luego caer,
como le pasó a Blockbuster,
que era el líder en alquiler
de películas VHS y DVD,
y luego fue cayendo más y más,
hasta llegar a la bancarrota.
El éxito es la suma
del éxito propio y del ajeno.
¿Qué quiere decir esto?
Que así como yo soy capaz de sumar
a más personas a mi idea y a mi sueño,
también debo tener la capacidad de poder
sumarme a los sueños de otra persona.
Para tener éxito es fundamental
que no tengan miedo a fracasar,
porque el éxito no es el destino,
es el camino.
Disfrútenlo.
(Aplausos)